selon vous quel chroniqueurs et le plus
lâche tout qu de cyril
[Musique]
alors benjamin gille jean louis van gall
[Applaudissements]
benji alors j pourquoi gilles parce que
n'eut pas d'amis d'amis vous oui alors
tu te fous moi ou
quoi moi c'est ça ton argument est tout
le temps dans le sens du patron verra
tous partent à lui brosse dans le sens
du poil dans le sens de personnes vu que
t'as rien à dire
pourquoi bac à main pourquoi pas demain
benjamin parce que sans vous il n'existe
pas et oui sa grande faiblesse et
pourquoi pas d'argent pas d'ami pas de
connaissance pas d'avenir rien en fait
il pas ce qu'il faut je le dis
respectivement la base a neigé le cul ou
[ __ ] voilà
et vous le savez très bien les aimants
c'est vrai que je ne sais pas
delphine haussier mais casta louis parce
qu'ainsi alors j'ai copié sur le gilet
en fait le monde amis vient donc chez
les frères vous allez me dire oui
j'entends est-ce qu'ils arrêtent pas
dire qu'est-ce qu'il évoquait ce qu'il
est bien habillé qu'est-ce qu'il est
brillant en fait oui mais tu le dit trop
en fait moi je viens paddle qui l'a
jamais vu jouer au paddle en fait ça n'a
aucun sens il a vu des le devoir des
vidéos oui on a tous répondu à la
question vous quelle est votre réponse à
cette question le plus le cul ouais
alors je vais vous dire je vous dis je
vous
décris est là d'abord où il est là non à
gauche ou à droite en chemise europe et
c'est moi
c'était la louisiane
jfr choix tactiques
le prix des secousses et guillaume
gille fait avant l'émission silva
djediat surpris en train de renifler
mauvaise
évoque les flots pas beaucoup